ALICE: Please help me welcome
to the stage Andrew Cyr
and members of
Metropolis Ensemble.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW CYR: Thank you, Alice.
Good afternoon, everyone.
It's an honor to be here.
I began Metropolis
Ensemble 10 years ago,
in part with a
simple guiding notion
that the heart of the
classical music tradition
really embraces and celebrates
exploration and discovery
and really the search for
new forms of expression.
You know, the great works
that make up today what
we call like the
repertoire, the canon
are often the ones that
represent-- for the composers,
they're kind of like
wildest experiments,
or their most bold sort of
unusual works performed.
But today we don't often
associate classical music with,
for example, technology or
groundbreaking new things.
But the instruments that we now
kind of are very traditional,
like the violin, or
the piano, or even
like the antiquated pipe organ--
at the time, these
instruments were
kind of really
newfangled inventions
and were kind of like the Google
of yesterday, so to speak.
New forms of
tuning, for example,
in Bach's time, and then later
advancements in chromaticism
with Wagner, for example--
these things that dazzled
musicians and listeners alike.
And they presented really
endless forms of variations.
Metropolis's first experiments
in music technology
really started in
2008 when we did
a remix of "The Rite of Spring"
with Ricardo Romaneiro, Ryan,
Francis and engineer Leo Leite,
and we never looked back.
Today, I'm very
thrilled to present
another one of our
roster composers
and close collaborators,
Elliot Cole, whose explorations
in original software, I
guess I should call it,
are interwoven with his
beautiful and evolving music
aesthetic.
He will be joined by a
handful of Metropolis Ensemble
musicians--
Eric Umble on clarinet,
Jordan Dodson on guitar,
Gabe or Gabriel
Cabezas on cello,
and Andrea Lodge on piano later.
So thank you so much,
and I hope you enjoy.
[APPLAUSE]
ELLIOT COLE: HELLO, everybody.
So we can switch now
to my screen here.
[MUSIC PLAYING -
METROPOLIS ENSEMBLE, "BLOOM"]
[APPLAUSE]
Right.
I'm Elliot Cole, and
I wrote that music.
And you're some of
the first people
to see behind the
scenes of how I started
thinking about those
patterns, how I started
working with that material.
And I'm excited to be here.
Usually I just present
the music and don't really
talk about programming.
I think that people
want to believe
that the music comes straight
from your soul and this bolt
of inspiration.
And I think that, I
don't know, people
don't want to imagine that it
spun out of a computer program.
So I'm excited that you
guys are listening now,
because I think you're
interested in programming,
right?
Great.
So you know that it's just as
much a world of inspiration
and discovery and expression
and as much as music or art.
So I don't have to
have to convince you.
So I'm just a self-taught
amateur programmer.
But I grew up with
a professional.
My mom taught herself
to program and ended up
coding GIS software for the
state of Texas in the '80s.
And I grew up--
she taught me HyperCard.
Do you remember HyperCard?
Did anybody-- yeah.
So me and her were doing
HyperCard projects together
when I was like
really a little kid.
And I chased music, but
I always kind of knew
in the back of my mind
that this was the thing
that I could come back to
and figure out on my own
if I wanted to when I needed to.
So I picked it up
about seven years ago
to start this project
that I have shown you now.
So tell you a
little bit about it.
It's called "Bloom."
And I started down the
rabbit hole of this music
because I for
inexplicable reasons
was fantasizing
listening to a music that
just sounded like this.
[MUSIC - ELLIOT COLE, "BLOOM"]
So I first started
trying to write music
like this at a piano.
I would lock myself in
a practice room, piece
of paper, pencil,
and I thought that it
would be kind of easy,
because all I wanted to hear
was random notes.
And you'd think it would be
easy to sit down and write
random notes.
Turns out it's really hard
to try to not make choices.
As soon as you're there
feeling every little thing,
you start to care about this
pull and this push, and are
these two things attracted?
Are they too much attracted?
Do we have to thwart them
with exactly the right note
at exactly the right time?
You can kind of
make yourself crazy
trying to make the perfect
thing when actually there's not
really a perfect thing to find?
This is what I started
to suspect as I
was trying to do it this way.
I like to think about art as
a dialogue between expression
and discovery.
Expression pulls something
out of us that's inside of us.
Discovery is something outside
of us that we bring in.
And I think when I was
trying to write this at first
at the piano I was trying to
express something of myself
in it.
I was trying to choose exactly
the right notes that only
I would choose.
But I-- really this was
the wrong path for me,
I think, because
it really needed
to be a music of discovery.
I really wanted to be able to
go out and find these things
and then make choices,
then care about them,
then figure out
which ones I liked.
So my mental image here is of
a garden, of a wild overgrown
garden.
And each plant is a little
constellation of notes.
And my job--
I was commuting on New Jersey
Transit like three hours a day
in this time in my life.
And I dreamed of just
being able to sit
with my eyes closed and
my computer half-shut
and just listen to bloom
after bloom after bloom
from this garden,
explore it with my ears,
and pick things that
I like and shape them
and transplant them and
make them a little softer
and make them a little fuller,
spin them around, try them
out different ways, and
make some kind of music
of subtle variations
of what I think
are kind of infinitely
beautiful, simple, random sets
of events.
So I wanted to do--
I thought a computer would
be a good way to approach it.
I thought of my mom.
I thought my mom would
say, just write a program.
You can do it.
So I started learning this
programming language called
SuperCollider, which
a lot of musicians
use because it's got
a synthesizer built in
and started trying to
represent my blooms.
So you'll see that
it's a class that
is really just three lists.
There's a list of notes,
a list of velocities--
it's a little confusing here.
Velocity here means
volume, basically.
It's how fast you play the key--
and time intervals.
This is how much time
is in between each note.
And then I wrote a
whole library of--
that's probably not
the technical word.
I wrote a whole bunch of
methods for this class
that you've seen
a bunch of already
for manipulating those
lists, basically.
And then I started
figuring out ways
to write patterns that
would read out these lists,
spinning infinitely
in every direction,
like you've also heard some of.
Those are the
experiments that turned
into a couple of
these pieces that I'm
sharing with you today.
So I just have a couple
of reflections of things
that I've learned about, and
then we'll hear some more music
on the piano.
So I've learned
a lot about music
from listening to a lot of
these random sets of notes.
And I think there are
three main things.
One is that making sense--
this feeling that we have
that something that we hear
makes sense--
what does that even mean?
Like, it's something
that we know,
but it's very hard to quantify.
I think it's about
making simple shapes
and being able to
perceive simple shapes.
So check it out each
of these blooms.
[MUSIC - ELLIOT COLE, "BLOOM"]
I don't know.
To me, they all kind of make
sense as musical gestures.
They make sense because there's
actually one dimension of them
that is in a simple shape.
So it's random notes,
random time intervals.
I better show it
to you let's see.
So random notes,
random velocities,
random time intervals,
but the velocities
are sorted largest to smallest.
So they start loud, and
then they get quieter.
And just by applying
this one envelope,
this one shape, across whatever
random materials is in there,
creates a gesture
that makes sense.
It feels like a single thing.
It feels like a whole.
So that's the first thing I
learned making sense in music
is about making simple
shapes in some dimension.
Second thing is that not every
dimension needs to make sense.
If you can make one dimension--
volume or pitch or
rhythm or timbre--
make a lot of sense, then
you get a lot of freedom
to let the other
things not make sense.
So those are the two
things that, even when
I'm not making music
with the computer,
I'm thinking about as
I'm making music now.
And then the last thing is
that memory is everything.
Whether or not we've heard the
sound before or not is actually
maybe the most salient flavor
compared to the content
of what's actually in there.
So let's do an experiment.
I'm going to play the
same line three times,
and I just want you to check
in with the experience of how
the first one feels
different from the third one.
[MUSIC - ELLIOT COLE, "BLOOM"]
A traditional musical
analysis would say, oh,
it's three identical
sets of pitches.
But the experience of them
is so different, right?
The first one is baffling.
And the third one is
like pretty satisfying--
to hear it exactly
the same way with all
of the subtle variation.
So I think that this is
why sitting at the piano
and trying to write this was
a little bit crazy-making.
There's no right or
wrong note to choose.
Notes don't matter
in themselves.
They come to matter through
repetition and familiarity
and having a relationship
with your memory.
So those are the things that
I've learned doing this.
And I'd like to share a little
bit more music with you.
I think because of time,
let's just do the nocturne.
Is that all right?
Great.
I'm going to do a
little intro, actually.
[MUSIC - ELLIOT COLE, NOCTURNE"]
[MUSIC
- ANDREA LODGE, "NOCTURNE"]
[APPLAUSE]
So they told me to save a
little time for questions.
So if you have questions, I'd
love to have a conversation,
and if not, there's a little
more music that we could do,
so what do you think?
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So I know there are visual
tools for manipulating music.
So how does this
programming language
help you above visual tools,
like Fruity Loops or whatever?
I'm not a musician,
so I don't know.
ELLIOT COLE: Yeah, yeah,
most of the software that's
kind of commercially
available to make music
is to make music easier, right?
So it's like designed to be
recorded, played in, maybe
clicked in, and
kind of composed.
But none of them let me
write an abstract pattern
irrespective of the
pitches that are
going to be in it, for example.
That's something that I
really want to be able to do.
I want to be able to
say, I want a series of--
I want this rhythmic pattern
to happen this many times.
I don't care what
the notes are yet.
And so being able to work
on that level of abstraction
is just not something that
Ableton or Fruity Loops
or Logic are designed to do.
So I like thinking about
this as music the hard way.
It's like a little
dumb to do it this way.
Sometimes I'll spend a lot of
time doing something this way
that I could have done
a much simpler way.
But certain things are
possible also through it.
AUDIENCE: Is this the primary
way that you create music?
ELLIOT COLE: Maybe like 33%.
Yeah, but it shaped my
thinking much bigger than that,
I think, in a couple of
the ways that I described.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ELLIOT COLE: Thank you.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming
and performing today.
ELLIOT COLE: Thanks
for having me.
AUDIENCE: So when you want
to have a musician play this,
do you have to do some
tweaking for the instruments?
ELLIOT COLE: Yeah, definitely.
So not all things are
possible on all instruments,
and so I have to have a pretty
good idea of the end goal.
One, when I'm thinking about
the patterns in the first place,
it's worth considering
what ultimately
is going to be playing this.
But also, then,
there's a stage--
you know I can spin out
stuff all day, and some of it
I get really excited about.
And I record it all.
But then there's the process
of turning it into a score.
And in the process of
transcribing, turning it
into notes on a page--
a whole lot of
editorializing opportunity.
It's hard not to make choices.
And then I started cutting
stuff, making things perfect,
fixing notes.
So there's a lot
of composition that
happens after this
initial burst of stuff.
And in that stage adapting
things to the instrument
is just something I do
on a note-but-note basis.
AUDIENCE: So you do
that manually, then?
ELLIOT COLE:
Super-manually, yeah.
It would be a fun project to
try to write the program that
filters out the
notes that couldn't
be done at the same time
on the guitar or something.
But honestly it would
take me three months,
and I might as well just do it.
AUDIENCE: First off, let me say
that was absolutely amazing.
ELLIOT COLE: Oh, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for that.
And then, I'm interested
in the aspect of licensing.
We know with software licenses,
we know with music licenses,
I am not sure if
that bloom class is
music, is an instrument, but
have you considered licensing?
ELLIOT COLE: It's written
amateurishly enough
that I think it would be maybe
a little frustrating for anyone
other than me to learn to use.
But it's written
in SuperCollider,
which is open source,
and so downstream it
needs to be open source too.
So I'm not in a position to
try to control what people
do with it or something,
if I'm thinking
of licensing the right way.
But I'd be happy to share it.
But it's a little quirky
and personal at the moment.
AUDIENCE: I'm sure I'm not
the only one in the room who
wants to play with it.
ELLIOT COLE: Oh, you
want to play with it.
OK, that's--
AUDIENCE: Links to anywhere?
Do you have a GitHub repo
somewhere we can look at it?
ELLIOT COLE: No, I learned
how to do that once,
and then I didn't
do it ever again.
So let me put my email
address right here.
I'd love to be in touch with
anyone who wants to geek out
about this stuff with me.
And I'd be happy
to share the code.
And it would probably
be a good project
to kind of get it cleaned up and
write a little documentation.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much.
ELLIOT COLE: Thanks for asking.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you can describe
for this specific
piece, just for fun,
the nocturne-- can you describe
the process of how you composed
it?
ELLIOT COLE: Yeah
well, so that's
one where the idea came
from playing around in code,
but then the
composition happened
in a much more traditional way.
So what I discovered
that I loved
is if you take a set of notes
that have different time
intervals between them
and different loudnesses
of each one, and then you just
double each entry, or triple
each entry, it's pretty magical
to hear three identical notes
with identical times in between
them, and then turn on a dime
to another set of four that are
really different, but also all
identical.
And so that was what
I discovered I liked
by just manipulating lists.
And then when it came to
writing this piece of music,
I kind of knew what I wanted
the motion in the melody to be
and then composed it at a piano,
feeling all the right notes
that I wanted to make, writing
this kind of linear bass
line moving.
So that's all kind of free
composed in the usual way.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So this instrument opens
a lot of possibilities.
I was wondering if compared
to more traditional
musical creation you
sometimes feel lost,
because you have
so many options?
ELLIOT COLE: Yes.
All the time.
Yeah, I feel very
lost, especially
given that there aren't a
lot of points of intersection
with the rest of the world
where it sort of makes sense
to anybody else.
So yeah, I mean I've
been challenging myself.
I'm part of a tradition of
music education and values
that is about challenging
itself to be a little lost
and find your own personal
way to put notes together.
And not having models
I guess let's me--
I don't know-- it's a loss that
makes me kind of confident,
because it's kind of just
between me and me, you know?
I don't know what
I need to do next.
But I have a way to dig in and
find something that excites me.
And I think that's
what it's for.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So here you've got
notes, velocities, and time
intervals to represent a sound.
How easy or hard is that
to transcribe to something
with multiple instruments, like
the first piece that you did?
ELLIOT COLE: Yeah, that just
brings in my other skills
as a composer.
So I may use this to generate
some big swath of material
and then say, oh, I hear this
line, which happened just
in a kind of random occurrence.
I hear these couple
in notes be connected.
I hear a melody happening there.
Maybe I'll extract
that and connect
those dots on a
single instrument,
or something like this.
There's not a kind
of computational way
that I think about that.
AUDIENCE: Have you ever
tried applying these methods
to instruments that are
percussion or non-chromatic
percussion?
ELLIOT COLE: Yeah, definitely.
I write a lot of
percussion music.
Actually, I write
more percussion music
than other music.
And it's a great way--
this also got me started
thinking about patterns
and cycles in the
abstract, which
is great for non-pitched music.
So all I would need
to do is switch
the instrument in my
virtual instruments
here to a percussion
instrument, and I
would be exploring a totally
different kind of sonic space
with the same ideas.
Are you a percussionist?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that was one
of the first things I started,
and I've moved to other things.
But I just thought
of the example--
we heard just the piano--
you tried either
other keyboards,
and I thought, well, why
keyboards, maybe just
a non-chromatic percussion?
ELLIOT COLE: It can be anything.
This is just a little slice.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thanks.
ELLIOT COLE: Yeah thanks.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Can you talk
about how the values that we
see in notes, velocity,
and time intervals
correspond to what we
would see in a more
traditional score, like how
you get from one to the other?
ELLIOT COLE: Yes,
great question.
I forget that this is
not a universal language.
OK, so here, this
first bloom is 67.
The first note is 67.
Note values are 0 to 127.
67 happens to be G4.
Velocities are also
values 0 to 127.
And so you know, 61 is
a very moderate volume.
And this is just in seconds--
0.9 seconds.
So high-low numbers in notes
is high and low on a score.
And velocities, you know,
we have forte to piano.
We have these kind of
traditional markings.
And the hardest one to
represent is time intervals,
because this is
just in raw seconds.
It's not on any sort
of rhythmic grid.
It's not in any kind of meter.
And so from a score music
notation point of view,
this is like outrageously
irresponsible and irrational
to have all of these
numbers in here.
But the biggest
struggle has been
trying to represent
these rhythms on paper.
AUDIENCE: You have a really
complicated line lower down.
ELLIOT COLE: I remember.
I practice that one.
This one.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
ELLIOT COLE: This?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was wondering if you
could explain [INAUDIBLE].
ELLIOT COLE: Yeah, sure,
so this is a pattern
that's reading through
one of those blooms,
so reading through each
note of the list in order.
And so I is which item of
the list it is reading.
Let's see.
We'll go inside out.
This is just a series
from zero to infinity.
And it's going to
wrap around my loop.
So this just represents going
through the list over and over
again.
Again Pclump is a pattern that
is going to not just take one
at a time, but take clumps at
a time and play them as chords.
And how many it takes at
a time is this argument.
And Pwhite is white noise.
It's just a random
number generator
between one and three.
So I'm saying spin out this list
of all of my notes in a circle
forever and grab either one
or two or three at a time.
And so it's a random mix
of chords and single notes.
Yeah, thanks.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]